I gotta say DC did the best they could
but they were being swarmed by the media
over my existence working there the
thing that leftists do that they're so
great at is they have accomplices in the
media that will write the articles that
you want them to write that they want
them to write and then those will get
published on The Daily Beast or any of
these awful like websites and then
they'll refer to those articles as proof
that you are exactly who they say you
are and then those get referenced in
Wikipedia your Wikipedia is soon
denouncing you as a whatever it is so a
white supremacist or whatever they're
calling you uh and uh anyway
um so that was uh that was that DC
Comics called me up and God bless them
they they tried to stand by me as much
as they could but
uh somebody who I really like there
friend of the family called me up and I
said am I okay is everything okay and I
could hear him pouring a drink into a
little glass I could hear the ice and he
just said we can't renew your contract